All right, greetings everyone. It is
September 9, 2022. It's the 15th meeting
for Cohort one and we are
discussing chapter six. We're in the
first of two discussions on chapter six
of the textbook. We're going to
go to the questions page and start there
where we have one question that we
explored a bit last week in our welcome
back. And then there's at least one
question prepared, but anyone is welcome
to add more questions here while we turn
first to this question. What are the
four steps in the recipe to construct an
active inference model?
And can we make templates that
facilitate people walking through some
of these stages?
How much model building do people prefer
to be engaged in in this section of the
textbook group? Do people want to have
one or more model that they're
personally developing?
Do they want those to be scaffolded
in a shared page to help increment
models along and see models at different
stages? Yeah, Brock and anyone else?
It's the same problem as, like, the
first half of the textbook without math.
It'S not going to go well. This half
without modeling,
it's going to be quite difficult, I
think. So I think we should just get
that out of the way that it's not about
whether you want to or not or whatever.
If you want to just understand it at a
cursory, philosophical, perhaps level,
then maybe not. But if you actually want
to understand it, then, yeah, we are
going to. Have to model something some
way. It doesn't have to be the most
complex, most precise one, but yeah,
I wonder if we could develop like maybe
a couple examples or simple.
Ones that. People might like to model.
I don't know. Those are all going to be
purely agent based.
Thanks. I agree. I wanted to frame it as
a question, but I agree with that
perspective. And following
along as we structure
a few specific cases, the rat and the
team maze, the icicating which
are used in the textbook, then some
of the examples that are used
recurrently in the literature, like
birdsong and a few others. And for
these, many scripts exist and
helping people who might
not have the setup either by with some
walkthroughs. Okay, here's how you get
octave running. So you can do this
MATLAB script or here's the standalone
dem demo because this textbook really
only gives the pointer to MATLAB scripts
and methods. Like when they say
that the standard schemes can be
applied, they mean a MATLAB script.
And that's exactly what the step by step
guide model stream one is built around.
And chapter seven on modeling in
discrete time is going to be
akin to the step by step guide. But it's
not step by step by step by step.
It's more like it takes two bigger
steps. Okay,
how is this four step recipe for
active inference modeling similar or
different than approaches that people
have seen for systems modeling from
other frameworks,
for example, in a reinforcement learning
or cybernetic modeling. So something
more recent and computational or
something more pre formal
or computational.
Should this recipe be surprising to
people coming from a certain background?
Are there substeps that are relevant to
consider? Brock yes.
I don't have extensive formal
modeling experience, but most
of the things that I've done for the
last half decade entail some form
of this. And I don't see how you
could model anything without going
through these basic questions
here.
I don't see how this is specific or
exclusive or whatever to active
inference. It's a bit ambiguous
to me. How that besides specifically
degenerative model, I guess. But.
Which system are we modeling? Another
way to ask that is what questions are we
trying to answer or
who? I think Lyle brought this up like,
who are you making the model for? Sort
of thing.
Because the same like you were saying
just earlier about the
particular choice of how you're modeling
it is just a choice
on that system, and that entails
particular kind of
hidden states, mark on blanket, et
cetera. That may
be relevant or may not be, depending on
the questions, what you're trying to
model, but that arises from those
questions, I guess, is what I'm saying.
Thank you. Ali.
Well, yeah, I just wanted to mention
that, referring back to your previous
question, I also am currently developing
a model, actually an emotion
perceiving agent by pretty much
closely following those four steps.
But I'm getting some helps in that
regard in how to actually implement
those four steps in my particular
situation. But on the topic of modeling,
well, at a very basic level,
we can categorize different
approaches to modelings in terms of
answering to three different questions
the what models, the how models, and the
why models. At least that's the kind of
approach mostly done in neuroscientific
modeling. So in my opinion,
these four steps and this recipe can
be applied mostly to
the how and the why.
What models are mostly mostly
descriptive models. But when
we want to model an agent and
self evidencing agent,
which behaves as if it
infers something about its environment,
we have moved beyond just the
descriptive stage and we're dealing with
the how and probably even the why
questions there.
Thanks. When I hear why, I always think
of Tin Bergen's four questions, the four
whys, aristotle's four whys.
Why is a subjective modeler's
pluralistic playground, and it
doesn't lend itself to one specific even
type of answer, let alone a framing or a
specific parameter combination. And I
think that's a huge aspect of the move
from like what are systems to how am I
going to model the system? Which is a
part of the turn that happens when we
start to model is we dispense with
absolutism. All of a sudden, these
questions about what we're trying to do,
our preferences and affordances and
constraints and limitations and
everything come into play and we might
make a portfolio of models that are
shining light on different aspects of
even the very same phenomena.
So it's kind of like an empirically
grounded pluralism and pragmatism when
we start to be engaged in real useful
modeling. And that is something that
I feel that one learns on the field,
not necessarily bystanding.
So that's just to say that the modeling
is really important, even for
philosophical reasons, to say nothing of
some of the things that are coming to
play in chapter seven and beyond, where
it's like, yeah, the C vector has this
many entries because why
and how many rows and columns does this
have? But once we understand why the
rows and the columns and the shapes of
these different entities are the way
they are, then we just have
to use this scaffold to think about
certain systems,
consider their form at a very structural
level, like is it in discrete time or in
continuous time and so on. And then
we might set up not just one generative
model, but again, families of them.
In the future, we hope and expect that
active block, for instance, will
facilitate us doing parameter sweeps
across families of cognitive models and
generative models. But even in this
boutique phase of model construction
that we're in in current year,
one would still say, okay, I want to
have one model where it's either
acceptable temperature or too hot, and I
want to have one with a three state
model. Too cold, just right, too hot.
Here's going to be a four stage model.
And just being able to specify that,
again, instills pluralism through action
about how we're modeling a system,
which is a philosophical point that it
seems like sometimes isn't grasped
by those who don't engage in the
specific discussions around modeling a
system.
Okay, so where does Figure 6.1
come into play?
It's a rehearsal of some of the figures
we've seen earlier in the book and many,
many other places. This is the
particular partition. The particle is
the internal and the active sensory
states. So internal plus blanket states
equals particular states. Those are the
particles. If we were looking at dust
under the microscope, like Brownian
Motion was describing, initially the
particles were the dust particle, and
then the external states were like that,
which was not the dust particle
partitioning the generative process and
the generative model off from each
other. We're dealing in Bayesian
mechanics with particular states,
with particles, with things that are
able to engage in sensory motor type
loops. This is just bringing in
a few more pieces
than that, which is just to call
attention to the direction and the
existence of the arrows in the work.
How particular is the free energy
principle of aguilera at all? And in
follow up work, there's discussion
around which topologies on
this particular partition facilitate
or enable which kinds of formal claims
to be made. For example, one might
find it kind of interesting that sensory
states have a bi directional arrow with
external states or might
find it equally interesting or
differently interesting or less
interesting that also active states have
an arrow pointing back to internal
states. And of course the
questions that we have raised all along
the way of like, okay, let's just say
that we're going to model a person's
arm. What are the active states,
what are the sensory states? What does
it mean that there's a bi directional
arrow connecting them? Is this the only
topology for this particular partition?
Could we have the around the clock model
external states influencing sensory,
then internal, then active and just
going around the clock without any cross
talk in the blanket, without any back
arrows? Is that plausible?
Does that change the formalism?
On one hand, how could it not change the
formalism when it's changing the
structure of how variables are related
to each other?
Or maybe there are formalisms that are
actually abstracted away from any
topology choice because
what is being described are the flows
and the gradients on these variables.
But then what are those variables.
That. Just highlights this need for
modeling? But if we just really briefly
go. Back to that, it's like
the fact that there's this bi
directional arrow between external
states and sensory states is
bit confusing in
that. Again, the language like well
if it is acting on the environment,
isn't that an action state or something
like this?
In what way is it bi directional? So
could you not draw that as one arrow
going to the sensory state and one arrow
from the sensory state back to the
environment and then say what
functionally does that entail? And then
you're doing this particular selection.
Of how you're modeling. Right. But I
think you have to do that.
To understand why that is bi directional
there right. In that particular framing
of the generative process generate model
there right.
Which is still to me also slightly
nebulous. But I think yeah,
just the bi directionality of it between
the action and sense states that kind of
makes sense almost that
you sense your actions and your actions
or response to your sense. But that's
not really what's being done there
precisely either. Right.
Just explicating. That is what we need
to separate and explicate what
yeah. Another really important question
is like this action perception loop is
appealed to early and often.
It's the first picture in the textbook
before the high road and the low road in
1.2 is eleven.
We're talking about agents and their
interfacing with the niche and we're
going to end up calling how we model
agents a generative model and we're
going to end up calling the niche and
the dynamics of the niche and how it's
influenced as the generative process.
And we're going to call the interface
between the generative model and the
generative process a Markov blanket and
it's going to inherit this technical
definition from Bayes graphs and we're
going to add these variables and we're
going to connect them a certain way.
But we're talking about the feedback
loop with the agent in the niche.
Oh, so what is this then?
Are the observations the sensory states?
And this isn't just like a low hanging
fruit like well then why couldn't
we call them? I mean, they are called as
X and Y. Interestingly in the continuous
time formulation and I get it that
they're being distinguished here because
this is the continuous time POMDP and
the discrete time POMDP.
But where do we see active
states here?
We see policies.
So are active states along the branch
influencing the B matrix how
the hidden states change through time?
So there may be a very simple trail
from this action perception loop
framing to the discrete
and continuous time POMDPs.
Yeah, I think just to me, the simple way
instead of thinking of this as a
circular thing where you're literally
going from one state to the next state
to the way you might to in a normal
state machine if you're thinking of no
when you have an active state,
however, it is changing. That is
necessarily entailing change in the.
Sensory external state and the internal
states and vice versa. Here with the
sensory states like that. If you perform
some action of some. Kind, there's some
active change in that state. Like you're
necessarily changing the internal hidden
state, right?
If you grab a
glass of water or something like this,
what you're modeling now has changed
slightly, right? And your internal
states and the sensory states are doing
the same thing where the glass of water
or whatever was this object
just sitting there doing nothing, but
now it's become a thing to drink out
of. And that's changed in some sense the
kind of external states that are being
fed into your sensory states. It's
changed the Markov blanket that you're
kind of selecting for or relating to.
I think that is visibly they're
doing the same sort of thing where if
you have this observation, you're
necessarily creating a new internal or
sense state that is going to change your
policy selection and that's
going to change your sense states.
So.
Returning to the recipe, one question
that I think will reduce our uncertainty
about as we really do the modeling is
how do we account for residuals and
understand which modeling residuals,
which is to say variability in data
that are not explained by the model,
which and what amounts of residuals are
acceptable? So if we were doing a linear
regression and the only data we had on
hand was height, and the only data that
we wanted to predict were weight, then
we could just say we've used all the
data and whether the model fits
with an R value of zero one or zero
nine, we know what the residual is of
height on weight regression. And here's
a number that describes what fraction of
the variability was described with this
regression? R value of one being like
it's all perfectly on a line. R value of
zero being like it's just a total
scatter plot. We can say how much
variability is explained and then we're
done with the empirical data that we
had. So we can't explain any more
variability when we're
looking at empirical traces of behavior
to explain even a small fraction
of behavior. For some systems, it might
be the case that the generative models
already must be quite complex.
In another scenario, it might be the
case that a very simple model like
looks to the left are 90% of
the time followed by looking to the
right. I mean on average,
isn't that true? So then when we are
evaluating models, whether in block,
for instance, sweeping across models or
just qualitatively or in a boutique way,
are we looking to reduce the residual to
zero? What traces of
data are we looking to explain
variability in? And then
if we're not going to be with empirical
traces of behavior looking to reduce our
unexplained variance,
what is going to be the criteria by
which we do model selection on the
AIC and the BIC, which are information
criteria, balance variability
explained across families of models
with their degree of parameterization
penalizing having more parameters,
rewarding better explanations. So
seeking to find a balance with models
that are on the kind of pareto frontier
of explanatory and simple,
that's great. That's like one extra
nuance. On top of merely explaining more
variability with a smaller residual, it
also adds in the penalty for having more
parameters. So that in theory
and in practice stops the modeler
from just, okay, well now we're going to
add in the temperature in this other
part of the world because 1% of the
variability just happened to be
explained. So now we're just developing
these like totally spiraling looking for
more and more data sources to explain a
decreasing amount of variability that's
left. So it's good to pull back from
that edge through the use of information
criterion. But at the core of the
criterion is still the imperative to
reduce the residual, to have a model
that fits within
a model the way that we fine tune it so
that it fits data well, but not
overfitting. And then across models we
can see an analogous process of wanting
the model structure that fits without,
for example, overfitting or over
including parameters.
So I think one question which might be
added here is like what data do we have
if we're doing a didactic model and we
just want to sketch it out and run a
simulation and just purely generate data
that might be useful in certain
settings. But the question
of what behavioral data we have is very
nontrivial if we're going to be
approaching this as an empirical
analysis problem. Brock just another
question there.
What observations must we make or
something is related to what data do
we have? If you don't have the data that
if there's not sufficient affordance
information contained in the data to
model the problem, then.
Do we have to model our action selection
at a second or third order?
Yeah, exactly. To realize the right
epistemic value.
Okay, so that was figure 61,
discrete and continuous,
shallow, deep and hierarchical.
So just to address
this, which might come up shallow
versus deep is describing how iterated
the model is through time,
within one type of time.
So you could have the 1 hour shallow
model where hours are our units, or you
could have the 10 hours where it goes
1234-5678, 910, or you could have 100
depth of 100 with a time click of one.
Or one could have a hierarchical model
where there's 10 hours that make like a
deca hour and then there's ten clicks of
the deca hour to reach a planning
horizon of 100 time steps.
So deep is describing within
one unit or counter of time
how iterated that counter is depth
is describing strict hierarchical
nesting and so they can both
be used separately or together to
describe events over longer and
longer time horizons.
Crucially, this is in the context of
language processing. The duration of the
word transcends that of any phoneme and
the sentence transcends that of any word
in the sequence. And if we assume
paragraphs are made of multiple
sentences, paragraphs always transcend
and encompass sentences. So anyone else
want to just add a point? I'm sure that
you fellows are familiar with this
distinction, but just wanted to point it
out since temporality in these models
and doing model selection on different
forms of temporality is going to be an
essential piece of the puzzle.
Yeah. And it also reminds me of the
Shankarian analysis theory that, if you
remember, we talked about earlier,
and it's hierarchical.
It's temporal hierarchy that tries
to describe the whole musical piece as
a kind of hierarchical layers, which I
think maps perfectly into this specific
example of language parsing because
that also is a kind of thing that
should ideally be modeled in
a very hierarchical way. But the
caveat here is unlike language, which is
at least in some languages, are
necessarily hierarchical, music is
at least tonal. Music or even nontonal
music are not necessarily they
don't necessarily have this hierarchical
structure. So depending on the kind of
music or the genre of music, we might
have either a very shallow
and non hierarchical structure or a very
deep one. So that's something that
I think again refers back to the kind of
system we're trying to model. But even
that kind of system needs to be more
specified in a more granular level in
order to have an effective modeling
strategy there. Thanks for bringing it
in that domain. It makes me think of
the intro, the chorus, the bridge, the
verse. Perhaps these are only in certain
genre of music, but analogously and then
the measure transcends any beat in the
measure with a special case of like a
one one time signature or something and
so on. And then, although language is
described in a strictly hierarchical
sense, I'm wondering how syntax and
grammar actually create kind of a
strange loop. For example, it's trivial
to say that phonemes are nested within
words and sentences and so on, but what
about the semantics of a sentence that
contains commas and exceptions?
And then at the end the speaker says the
previous sentence is not how you think
it is. That is also
causing kind of like a deep linguistic
recall that can
be trivially modeled as containing
nested units. But will
a model that narrowly considers
the semantics of words, then the
semantics of clauses, how will it be
able to address some of these questions?
Here I think we can point to a really
excellent attribute of the active
inference modeling framework. So in
this discussion where the LW paper was
cited, we could just
marvel at nested systems and draw
blankets on blankets and so on. They
could be drawn around every organelle
and every little lipid granule in the
neurons or the brain regions. And so we
discussed a little earlier like doing
structural model selection on which one
of those are relevant. However, this
does not mean we need to attempt to
model the entire brain to develop
meaningful pragmatic simulations of a
single level. For example, if we wanted
to focus on word processing, we could
address some aspects without having to
deal with phoneme processes.
This means we can treat inputs from
parts of the brain drawing inference
about phonemes as providing observations
from the perspective of word processing
areas. So one could say I'm
going to make a figure 4.3 where
S is the true word and phonemes
are being passed as observations to my
word inference engine. And someone can
say but aren't phonemes the result of
inference? And someone can say great,
make that module in blockprints, make
that module and pass me that data.
And then we can do a nested model and we
can graft those models together, but
through the Markov blanket formalism,
not even the whole Markov blanket
bounding a specific particular entity,
but just the trivial Markov blanket that
exists insulating any two unconnected
nodes in a base graph. We can use that
broader, still technical concept of a
Markov blanket and just say all right,
phoneium observations come in and surely
we could make a model where another type
of information comes in and the
inference is on phoneme and that's
what's passed out. So I
think again to point to this advantage
of active inference modeling. It allows
us to situate
phenomena as complex multiscale nested
systems and also bite
off what we can chew and makes it an
empirical question of how grafting
together which different structures
might be useful. But we don't
need to go
all the way like turtles all the way
down. We can just say, even if it were
turtles all the way down. We're modeling
the third through the fifth turtle. And
the fifth turtle gets a top down prior,
and the third turtle gets sensory input
from one below it. And that's the part
of the stack. And this is the lateral
width that we're modeling.
Another advantage of active inference,
which not even saying this is a unique
advantage, is that this goal
directedness and corollary capacities
like counterfactuals on goals and the
way that counterfactuals on world states
influence our goal selection, nested
goals and transient goals or
conditional goals can be resolved
in an unfolding action perception loop.
That's something that as this example of
like wanting to enter an apartment,
of being goal driven over
multiple timescales and then being able
to again zoom in. So it's like, oh,
grab the keys. Okay, well here's the key
grabbing module. And someone says,
well, the key grabbing is actually
accomplished through this kind of
grasping behavior, then that
could be modeled. Or you can just say
we're subsuming finger grasping
kinetics in the grasping module
because the phenomena that we're trying
to explain and the data we have is just
about when things were grasped or maybe
the only observations we have is when
apartments were entered. So we can
actually, I expect,
frame systems extremely expansively
and clarify where we're doing formal
modeling.
I think maybe this
is just a philosophical or ontological
framing of it, but I don't see how you
can model anything well
without admitting that it is either
incomplete or partially
consistent or that
there is some hidden state which is
probably not included in the model. And
to me, active inference kind of.
Natively has an affordance,
at least at the very least a bookmark to
do that.
And so whatever depth
or hierarchy you model the system.
It'S okay. It's okay that there's still
hidden state and it's incomplete. If it
sufficiently models answers the question
at hand, then you can always add
another layer or make the model more
complex. And that's just what we were
going to do anyways.
Nice comment. I totally agree with that.
Again, thinking back to the linear model
example, where is that
extra information about adjacent
possibles for the model?
It's unstructured. It's kind of like
either the structured information is
going to enter your linear regression
just so and everything that's outside of
your linear regression is we're going to
need to go back to the square one. If we
include a second observable, we're going
to have to go to square one and do the
model selection all over again and test
for all the repeat interactions again.
But in these multiscale models that
we're discussing, like you said, it was
a bookmark. It's kind of a nice way to
frame it, which is like the phonemes
you're bookmarking or leaving an open
USB port or something.
Anything that outputs a phoneme
will plug into that part of the model
anything that is able to
hear can be plugged in to
the frog riveting. Anything that can see
can be plugged into the visual component
of the frog. And so it's
almost like consistent with all of this
blanket talk, we're being clear about
what is modeled formally, and the
borders of the formal model are
degrees of freedom as
formulated to be expanded upon
and composed.
One other, I'm not
sure the context is something I heard
Ben Gertzel say attributed to Pink
Schweight, but Pei Wang that in circular
reasoning, when your circle. Gets big
enough, it becomes coherent.
Maybe another way of saying like, that
if your model is insufficient,
that if. You.
Add enough states enough, if you
expand your blanket enough, eventually
if you're modeling something correctly,
I guess the generative
process can match
your blanket states can can come into
alignment.
Nice. Some more active inference
isms so exteriorceptive proprioceptive,
interceptive. We're going to use active
inference modeling memory, attention,
anticipation, planning as inference.
We're going to use active inference.
That is what it looks like. To integrate
disparate fields using one model,
one family of models.
Others can work out some fun
ways to communicate and frame it.
But I think when people are like, how is
this simplifying when it might feel like
it's bringing in a lot or even stepping
on namespaces that people already have
familiarity in? Like we discussed
earlier,
you could ask, how is memory related to
attention? Or perhaps more saliently,
how will you model how memory is related
to attention? Are you
going to go on archive and just look for
neural network architectures? Are you
going to read a book written
before computers were invented and look
at prose? Are you going to
dive into the psychoanalytic tradition
or something that's maybe even
clinically, biomedical what's
the move? And active
inference addresses that's
in these theme
of words that people use that mean
different things. For 400, we have
Bay's optimal behavior. Well,
then why do things go wrong?
And there's multiple layers to unpack.
First is going wrong is about
your perspective on how the system,
perhaps how you prefer it to be or how
you expected it to be. But given where
you put the dish when it
fell off the table, that was just
compatible with gravity. So it was
finding its optimal position and
fragmentation where you placed it.
The ball rolled downhill as a
consequence of where it was placed and
the slope it was on,
and framing behavior
in that light, we're modeling
behavior as rolling to the bottom of a
bowl. What's the bowl? What's the ball?
Those are the questions. But it's like
chemical reactions proceeding under
Gibbs free energy minimization when we
have policy selection driven by
variational and expected free energy
minimization.
But how can things that go wrong be
optimal?
Well, it has to do with different
parameters in the model, given how they
are. The model performs optimally.
That doesn't mean computationally
efficiently. It doesn't mean adequately,
doesn't mean it satisfies, but it
may be framed as Bayes optimal fixed
and learned behaviors. This is
going to come into play in chapter
seven. There's an amazing continuity in
theory and in simple examples with
perception and learning, which is to say
that perception happens over faster
timescales or perceptive like processes
happen over faster timescales while
learning like processes happen over
slower timescales. Or even just more
generally, perception and learning refer
to parametric update processes,
and you might even be able to situate
the same example both ways. Like if we
see a ball move across our visual field,
are we perceiving the location of the
ball? Are we inferring the location of
the ball or are we updating and learning
our position of the ball? For those with
a computational background, learning
often equates to parameter updating.
And so in that sense any kind of
dynamical perception is learning.
So for some backgrounds the difference
between perception and learning will
be seamless. For other backgrounds,
those are going to sound like totally
different processes. I mean, isn't
perception when you see the book? But
then learning is like when you
understand something about the book and
then speaking from a more modeling
perspective, here a fixed model or
fixing a parameter of a model reduces
the model's complexity immensely. Or
another way to say it taking a fixed
parameter and making it learnable
introduces multiple hyperparameters.
And there's no single way to address
parameter learning. You could say,
well, we're doing moving average
learning like a column filter or just a
simple sliding window. We're taking the
average of the last three. But now you
have to parameter sweep across how many.
And with a single trial of data,
it may not be clear which learning
strategy is implemented because
especially if we want to differentiate
learning strategies empirically, we
would want to see like multiple
comparable trajectories within and
amongst individuals in similar and
different contexts. But now our
lab has gotten quite big and we're doing
quite large model selections even
for learning and updating
parameters that might just
conversationally seem really simple like
preferences being updated.
So here's this description of when
it comes to inference and perception as
being fast changes and learning as
slower changes, though they're being
modeled in a really analogous way.
It is worth noting in this book we
exemplify rather simple generative
models that are defined using tabular
methods, e. G with explicit matrices or
tensors for priors and likelihoods in
small state spaces. In comparison,
more sophisticated GMs are being
developed in machine learning, deep
learning, robotics, et cetera.
So is active inference deep learning
okay, good fellow generative,
adversarial networks,
but with Bengio and
Mirza. But are
we saying those are formally active
inference systems or
are we just saying that we can think
of it like birdsong conceptually?
And then are we just adding a wrapper or
a descriptor to the gans that our non
active colleagues are building is it
shining any new epistemic or Pragmatic
light on Gans?
I mean, here's a whole paragraph on Gans
behind. Oh, that's chapter ten.
What happened? But there's still a whole
paragraph on Gantz.
Did you see that?
How did that happen?
Whoa.
I'm not sure what the optimal way to
view a PDF is or that one exists,
but I don't think it's the browser.
It's not bad, but it's not optimal.
I'm interested in, again the
generative model. Oh, I know what those
are. So, generative model and how
specifically Gans here an active
inference. Is the
rectangle a square? Sorry, square
rectangle rectangle not a square here.
Is that what is being said or is there
an indexed blanket here of varying
degree? Yes,
as far as I know. And and also you
fellows might know like this
is being pointed to variational auto
encoders and variational Bayesian
inference are directly implicated as
potentially recursive cortical networks
are and world models.
But if these bridges can be made solid,
like you said, with squares and
rectangles so that we can say all some
or none of X-R-Y
or here's how you project this model to
that model. It's going to just break
a dam with possibly
certain applications of active.
Any final comments on six, and I
think certainly by two weeks from now,
let's look at the SPM implementation
and look at some of those that are
pointed towards in the book, as well as
some of like the epistemic chaining and
Pi MDP type models, as well as anything
that anyone else builds. So, any final
comments? Yeah,
I just wanted to point out the recent
work by Fields at all, especially the
two papers that first and was also
the co author of. One of their
main objectives is to cross that bridge
between active inference and VAE via the
CCCD system. So that bridge
they're talking about in this book is
already being investigated to be filled.
So yeah, they're pretty interesting
developments going in that regard.
Okay, any last notes before I stop the
recording? What is that paper?
I'll send you the link from the discord.
I forgot. Maybe just one.
I don't know. We haven't trying
to make an effort on the code to lay
down some basic examples
from the first half, but should
there be some?
If we're going to model stuff, should we
have a sub page for that or do put
something somewhere in the code of for
that? I don't know. We've had this code
section from the beginning.
However, it should be totally
modifiable, full control.
So however this and anything sub pages
need to be modified and the GitHub link
to a textbook,
anything that people suggests, just let
us know.
Anything else.